[Música]
boa tarde a todos
eu sempre fui daquelas crianças muito
curiosas não sei se conhecem aquela
criança que se responde porque é porque
sim e porque é porque sim nunca uma
resposta e essa criança foi crescendo e
quando ela foi crescendo as perguntas
foram ficando cada vez mais complexas e
com perguntas cada vez mais complexas as
respostas eu fui encontrando um lugar
cada vez menos óbvios na mitologia grega
core é filha de meter a deusa da
agricultura quando ocorre é raptada por
hades
ela entra no submundo e se transforma em
perséfone sua mãe desolada sentindo a
sua falta começa a deixar de produzir e
torna a terra mais infértil zeus
preocupadíssimo que toda a humanidade
estava passando fome se falar com as de
falar desde que perséfone volta ao mundo
dos vivos para que todos possam comer
assim se faz e quando percebe e volta
para a sua mãe temos a primavera eo
verão quem a terra fica fértil em que de
meta está feliz quando percebe volta pro
colo dead seu amado
sua mãe saudosa não produz mais e aí
temos o outono inverno
a minha entrada em perséfone meu
primeiro momento de psf não tinha 12
anos
eu cheguei em casa com uma cólica
estranha eu baixei a calça baixa
calçinhas centeio não acreditava no que
estava acontecendo
eu chorei muito choro e muita tristeza
eu chorei de muita dor porque eu sabia
que a partir daquele momento nunca mais
voltaria essa primavera eterna submissa
vulnerável achar perna fala baixo fica
atrás de um grande homem uma grande
mulher
do mesmo jeito que a terra improdutiva
escassa
precisamos colocar sementes em cima dela
precisamos mexer constantemente que ela
tem
naquele dia chorei de muita tristeza
alguns anos depois eu me recusei a comer
na hora que se nervosa com 16 anos e eu
rejeitei qualquer alimento dentro do meu
corpo rejeitando o meu próprio corpo
enquanto mulher 90% dos casos de
anorexia nervosa no mundo acontece com
mulheres nesses dois momentos o que eu
não sabia era que o meu maior canal de
conexão com o universo com todos os
seres seria através da comida da
observação da natureza e do meu próprio
corpo
desde então vem questionando vem
questionando cada vez mais e as
perguntas vão ficando cada vez mais
complexas e eu fui observando a natureza
observando meu próprio corpo e foi
entendendo 7 percepções que gostaria de
compartilhar com vocês é um pouco o
percurso dessa procura de tentar
entender será que essa verdade que foi
contada por tantas pessoas tantas vezes
é uma verdade que me cabe submisso à
escassa frágil infértil atrás de um
grande homem ou será que eu posso mudar
tudo isso
perguntando é questionado sobre o
processo é esse tentar entender que que
negócio é esse de sangue menstrual que
sai de mim
será que o sangue comum e eu fui
perceber que na verdade nós temos uma
caminha no nosso ter chamado endométrio
e quando o nosso alvo não é fecundado
essa caminhada la pronta para receber o
cheio de nutrientes para transformar
aquela sementinha não ser esse a gente
não ovula essa sementinha e sim do metro
é jogado para fora cheio de nutrientes
então essa sementinha que não foi
fertilizada dentro do nosso corpo fotos
e fertilizada cá fora eu comecei a usar
um coletor menstrual e comecei a colocar
o meu sangue na terra como fazer as
minhas ancestrais são milhares de anos
atrás e quando comecei a colocar o meu
sangue na terra eu entendi a fertilidade
que isso tem
e aí eu entendi que não têm como pular
essa etapa que eu e natureza
estamos feitos da mesma matéria que eu
sou um microcosmos de que acontece com
ela e que nós estamos na verdade cada
vez mais conectadas à natureza cada vez
mais conectados do chico naturais que
existem dentro do nosso próprio corpo e
que essa de conexão que faz com que
tenham que a gente acredito que precisa
de plantar toneladas de soja e de milho
para alimentar todo o planeta porque a
terra não é soberana
essa de conexão que faz com que a gente
busque padrões
faz com que a gente acha que todas as
abobrinhas e todas as bananas de mercado
têm de ser iguais e que 30% do que é
produzido no planeta é desperdiçado ou é
perdido grande parte porque não está
dentro do padrão e essa padronização da
terra foi um padronização que aconteceu
também com o meu corpo quando eu decidi
deixar de comer que me garantia queria
ser igual alguém pra que seria alguém
numa terra que é diversa natureza que é
adversa então entendi que eu sou ciência
e eu sou natureza essa ciência que
separou da natureza e que fez com que
milhares e milhares de mulheres fossem
queimadas e fogueiras há muitos anos
atrás ou não tantos anos assim porque
ela era enfermeira celas eram curandeira
celas eram parteiras elas eram
cozinheiras o meu pai tem uma mercearia
desde os 8 anos de idade e meu pai
sempre trazer uma caixa cheia de frutas
para casa eu sempre corria para
encontrar com ele falava papai tem
morangos criança que não gosta de
morango que ficava indignado eu ficava
desolado que meu pai não me trazia
sempre morango como é que é possível se
o meu pai me ama seu sabe que eu gosto
de morangos como é que não tem morango
inteiro e meu pai foi me ensinando esse
trânsito das frutas nem sempre vai ter
morango filha mas vai vir lancia
aí depois vai virar laranja no outono aí
depois vão ver raízes no inverno e
quando fui me apercebendo e começando a
perguntar porque é que isso era desse
jeito eu entendi que a melancia chega
quando eu preciso me tratar e ela tá
cheia de água
a vitamina c da laranja chega no outono
porque eu preciso me preparar para o
resfriado do inverno chegar
as raízes estão lá para nutrir o meu
útero no inverno quando eu cheguei
quando eu preciso de me acolher então
entende que na verdade natureza ela tem
uma conspiração silenciosa para que eu
possa existir em prazer profundo e amor
incondicional que ela me pede retorno
que o quanto é semente dela ela me seduz
com uma manga maravilhosa para que eu
jogue a semente de volta na terra e ao
entender isso também entende que as
quatro estações do ano que essa
simplicidade o que acontece com demetri
com a terra em cima acontecem no mundo
lá em baixo
acontece dentro de mim eu sou primavera
eu só alegria e eu saio correndo com o
encantamento quando eu fico alegre
mas eu também bato bolo quando estou com
raiva
eu choro e pego na música mais triste
que é possível e eu aguento meu inverno
eu suporto meu inverno eu vejo potência
em todas as etapas porque eu não sou
linear porque o super cef não socorre
mais eu tive a oportunidade de coordenar
um projeto há algum tempo atrás chamado
comigo feminino eram os três mulheres
enquanto a gente encontrou as três muito
curiosas viam-se crianças me parece dias
comigo
nós decidimos olhar os mapas menstruais
cada uma
quando é que cada uma estava menstruando
nossa você está nessa semana eu estou
naquela como é que o seu comportamento
quando se está na lua crescente quando
seu time england quando se está pré
mestrual pré ovulatória a gente mapeou
abre uma planilha de excel e mapeou onde
cada uma estava menstruando nós
gerenciamos todo o projeto com base
nesse calendário
eu estou mais mestrado nem o primeiro
nesse momento então faça tudo que texto
proler passa pra mim porque estou bem e
introspectiva nossa mas eu tô na lua
acrescentando que a planilha manda pra
mim porque estou ótima para produzir
planilha está na fase regulatória tem
reunião deixa que eu lhe dar a reunião o
projeto fluiu maravilhosamente imaginem
que seria introduzir isso dentro das
empresas todas as mulheres poderem
analisar os seus mapas menstruais e
entender a potência que existe entre
cada um deles
eu duvido de alguém que seja mais
concentrada do que a administração e eu
duvido que tenha alguém seja mais
produtiva do que o condutor lado
acumulando neste momento entende que a
situação não é doença como também
entende que praga não é doença praga é
professora ela só nos diz tem alguma
coisa muito errada acontecendo com a
terra porque não tem praga na floresta e
porque também não têm doença quando a
mulher se unem por que não é pra gente
está separado como não é pra fazer uma
monocultura em cima da floresta
se as plantas colaboram entre elas a
praga não acontece
se nós colaboramos entre nós a
menstruação deixa de ser uma dor
somos cronológica
eu achei muito estranho quando cheguei
no brasil há sete anos atrás e comecei a
observar as frutas secas rabanada papai
noel do lado do coco vendendo na praia
aí eu comecei não entender porque natal
aqui era celebrado igual celebrava o em
portugal de onde eu venho e eu fui
tentar entender o que acontecia antes do
natal que acontecia antes desse
calendário gregoriano e desse calendário
cristão que a gente segue até hoje em
todo o lado uma grande maioria dos
lugares sem muito olhar crítico sobre
ele e desde há muito tempo atrás de
nossos ancestrais que celebrar o
nascimento do deus sol no sushi do
inverno na noite mais longa começa a
adentrar o primeiro grande raio de sol e
as manhãs dos dias vão começar a crescer
até chegar no pico do solstício do verão
então por todo o planeta sempre existe
uma celebração do sushi do inverno como
nascimento do rei sol em várias
religiões a gente vai identificar esse
período
ali entre 21 e 25 de dezembro como
período do nascimento do grande deus que
tem uma relação com o solstício do
inverno só que aqui o natal acontece no
seu xvii do verão
então a gente fica comendo coisas que
não fazem muito sentido tem um
pinheirinho que vem das florestas da
noruega que era enfeitado para chamar
primavera para atrair a primavera e
abundância da primavera e quando eu
comecei a pensar sobre isso entendemos
por que será que também a páscoa
acontece no final do outono
se não sei se você sabe mas a páscoa em
inglês chama exterior e ster provém da
palavra ostara que é uma deusa celta que
celebra toda a fertilidade no equinócio
da primavera e é representada com o
coelho e um ovo
então se a gente começa a pensar porque
páscoa está acontecendo é que nós outono
porque já está comendo abóbora que é um
alimento do inverno no que nós da
primavera no halloween
então quando comecei a entender isso
entende qual é o tempo que eu quero
seguir é um tempo imposto numa roma do
século 15 é o tempo da terra ou entender
como é que tá a lua e eu entender em que
período do ano eu estou e quando entendi
isso do ponto vista anual na terra
entende dentro do meu corpo que a cada
28 dias
a lua muda e os ângulos e isso continua
e ela fica minguante e eu fico lap chan
e ela vai obstruir e ela cresce o
funicular e ela vai lá no topo la toya e
isso acontece todos os 28 dias então
entendi que até
ela é um cronológica ela é o a minha
agenda e o meu corpo marca o tempo
também a gente pode observar é o mundo
de acordo com cada sentido
ou a gente pode permitir observar que os
nossos cinco sentidos pode olhar uma
maçã ea gente só consegue a massa com
luz
elemento fogo pode tocar maçã
a gente toca a maçã com a matéria
elemento terra
a gente chega à mansão a gente só
consegue chegar com arte
o fato a gente prova maçã tenta ter
sabor sem água elemento água e observar
tudo isso
de um ponto de vista integrado é ter
etérea os cinco elementos da natureza
existem dentro do meu corpo na percepção
que eu tenho sobre tudo e isso só quer
me dizer a mesma coisa existe uma
conspiração para que eu consiga viver em
plenitude em prazer absoluto
se isso não é amor incondicional eu não
sei o que quer eu estava numa palestra
algum tempo atrás eu tive a oportunidade
de conversar com o pessoal que trabalha
com agroflora stan lee entende que a
agrofloresta o que é mais importante é a
poda das árvores porque a poda das
árvores faz com que a árvore deixe cair
que o que não lhe pertence mais e
fortalecer as raízes
comecei a entender o que eu tô dando eu
quero deixar cair e pesquisando sobre
isso eu fui descobrir que existe uma
semideusa da poda filha da deusa da
agricultura na antiga roma e que sempre
que é poder é feita nas florestas as
mulheres se reuniam celebravam em prazer
e trocavam carícias e trocavam festejos
os homens não eram permitidos de entrar
nessa festa não sei que trouxessem
alguma contrapartida à semelhança da
poda se chamava de e às vezes tá na
hora de amputar aquilo que não nos cabe
mais e construir a nossa própria verdade
sobre a terra e sobre quem nós somos
então sejamos poda do que não nos cabe
mais para que as nossas raízes que
fortaleçam e somos tabu
menstruação é tabu trazer feminina é
tabu quanto os outros tabus hoje pode
enumerar aqui e que seja tabu tabu é
palavra polinésia pra sagrado
então se está falando de tabu de prazer
que é tabu nos permitamos ao nosso tabu
possamos sentir o nosso prazer possamos
sentir o prazer da terra possamos honrar
o prazer à terra porque se é pra ser
tabu então que seja tabu integralmente
que a gente aceite o nosso corpo como
sagrados nossos ricos como sagrados o
ciclo da terra como sagrado e deixe de
tentar interromper e transformar isso em
uma linearidade padronizada porque não
cabe mais essa verdade não cabe mais foi
amputada no ponto 6
já passamos então que todas permitamos
ser tabu de nós mesmas
essa série de percepções fizeram com que
eu entendesse
alguns anos depois ou 272 lunações
depois dos meus 12 anos que aquele choro
não eram choro de tristeza não eram
choro de dor não era um choro de medo
que eles escolheram chorar de raiva era
um surto de fúria porque quem se permite
quem tem o discernimento de me chamar de
vulnerável de me chamar de frágil de
chamar terra de escassa
se ela tem 300 mil espécies comestíveis
e nós consumimos 200
quem se atreve a dizer que eu sou frágil
que eu sou infértil que eu sou o que
seja eu tenho que o tempo dentro de mim
eu carrego universo dentro do meu corpo
se o cíclica cerca de 28 dias o céu
mudou o mundo
quem se atreve a dizer ea falar sobre a
minha beleza padronizar a nossa beleza
se todas sons abundantes todas todas
somos potência
quem se atreve a continuar com esse
paradigma que faz com 40 mil mulheres
são estupradas por ano no brasil com que
13 sejam vítimas de feminicídio que faz
com que o cerrado esteja sendo destruído
que a amazônia seja destruída
quem se atreve esse choro é de fúria de
fúria de todas nós quem se atreve a
dizer que mulher não trabalha com mulher
que mulher não é amiga de mulher que a
gente só compete
quando nós quando estamos juntas e saber
disso as nossas menstruações se alinham
se isso não é pra gente ficar junto eu
não sei o que é
e quem se atreve a condenar e apontar o
dedo para os úteros não nasceram todas
as mulheres e todos os homens enquanto a
gente não fizer as pazes com a natureza
com ciclos com nosso corpo feminino que
existe dentro de todos nós
essa foi a primeira divisão que
aconteceu a gente não vai conseguir
ultrapassar mais nenhuma das separações
isso também era um choro além de ser de
fúria eram sua esperança pelos filhos
que ainda vai gerar pelas mães para que
todas as mães no futuro não precisam de
passar pelo medo que a minha mãe passava
cada vez que eu queria sair com os meus
amigos eu tinha medo que acontecesse
alguma coisa comigo simplesmente porque
eu sou mulher
é um grito de esperança e um choro de
esperança para que a minha filha nada
com seis anos irmãzinha dela com quatro
anos continuam dizendo como ela já dizem
hoje eu sei que eu sou muito forte por
dentro
mesmo que não consiga subir naquela
árvore mônica eu sou muito forte por
dentro é o grito de esperança é a sua
esperança para que todas as meninas para
que todas as mulheres para que todas nós
saibamos que a terra é uma mulher e o
nosso útero é o universo e que a gente
se sinta muito privilegiada tinha grande
chance da gente sair sem útero e já
nasceu com 1 tinha grandes chances de
ele não poder gerar vida ea gente pode
então que a gente se sinta muito
privilegiada pelo poder que a gente tem
pela potência que a gente é pela beleza
que dispor dentro da gente então esse
choro é pra mim é pra todos vocês é para
toda humanidade que a gente possa
transformar essa verdade e recriar uma
verdade nova para o que é o feminino e
ao que ana terra nesse mundo
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]